wir starten unsere sendung mit einer
breaking news es gab nämlich einen
furchtbaren unfall in baden württemberg
ein linienbus wurde von einem
regionalzug erfasst das ganze passierte
an einem bahnübergang bei blaustein im
alb-donau-kreis knapp 15 minuten von ulm
entfernt airbus hat nach dem unfall
feuer gefangen ist ausgebrannte zug
sprang teilweise aus den schiene soll
mehrere verletzte gegeben haben
teilweise schwer und wir schalten jetzt
direkt zum unglücksort zu unserem
reporter thomas heckmann dort für uns
thomas was kannst du uns über den
unfallhergang und diese gegenwärtige
situation berichten der unfallhergang
ist ungeheuer kurios weil es gab
eigentlich schon vorher einen
verkehrsunfall hier hatte es geregnet
auf der kreisstraße ist ein
motorradfahrer alleinbeteiligt gestürzt
er hat sich die schulter gebrochen der
rettungshubschrauber war deswegen im
einsatz stand direkt neben dem
bahnübergang und durch diesen unfall und
die versorgung des verletzten hat sich
der verkehr gestaut dann ging es weiter
es kam unter anderem ein linienbus der
wollte auch hier vorbei das ging nicht
weil der verkehr staute und in dem
moment schließen sich die schranken der
bus fahrrad wohl noch versucht irgendwie
nach links auszuweichen was auch immer
da war man sieht es ja auch die schranke
direkt noch soweit dran und dann
passierte das schreckliche eben mit etwa
120 km/h kam der regionalexpress aus
richtung blaubeuren angefahren aus einer
rechtskurve heraus der konnte auch der
lokführer überhaupt nicht auf dem
bahnübergang sehen und rammt eben diesen
bus der bus selbst wurde ja eigentlich
richtig vom bahnübergang weggeschleudert
hat sich um 180 grad gedreht dabei ist
auch der bus in flammen aufgegangen der
zug selber ein zweiteiliger triebwagen
der ist mit dem vorderen drehgestell
entgleist ist einfach noch 100 150 meter
durch den schotter gerutscht und ist
dann zum stehen gekommen auf halber
strecke zwischen den beiden habe ich
übrigens den motorblock vom bus gefunden
ja und durch den aufprall ist der bus in
flammen aufgegangen der ist vollkommen
ausgebrannt zum glück keine fahrgäste
drin der busfahrer selbst wurde aus dem
bus heraus geschleudert wurde
lebensgefährlich verletzt auch der
lokführer ist schwer verletzt und im zug
waren 74 fahrgäste von denen sind wohl
den meisten unverletzt es ist die rede
von ein bis zwei schwerverletzten und
einer unbekannten anzahl der
leichtverletzten
ja wirklich wahnsinnsbilder und einen
wahnsinns vorfall der da passiert ist
thomas kannst du schon sagen wie lange
dort der unfallort jetzt erstmal
gesperrt wird vor allem die ganze bahn
strecke ist im moment auch nicht
befahrbar wie lange wird das so bleiben
kann man das schon sagen also die
bundesstraße 28 von blaubeuren nach ulm
die für tja hier direkt an der
unfallstelle vorbei die versuchen die
rettungskräfte gerade so man zumindest
mal einspurig wieder frei zu bekommen
die bahnstrecke selbst das wird wohl
nach ersten schätzungen hier vor ort für
tage nichts werden also die bahn die
blaubeuren ulm wird mehrere tage
blockiert bleiben das liegt einfach
daran dass natürlich der zug erst mal
geborgen werden muss der entlastet da
ist das technische hilfswerk vor ort die
überlegen jetzt natürlich die sie diesen
zug der links und rechts nur acker keine
festen wege überhaupt angehoben und
wieder eingelöst werden kann und dann
muss man auch die gleisanlagen
reparieren
hier sind einige schwellen einfach
zerbröselt weil der zu geben mit den
rädern drübergefahren ist es ist auf
bestimmt 50 meter der schotter voller öl
also das ganze wird mehrere tage dauern
und natürlich die schrankenanlage ist
auch weggerissen die sollte natürlich
auch wieder instand gesetzt werden
thomas heckmann uns zugeschaltet von
unfallort dort in baden württemberg wo
ein regionalzug in ein bus gecrasht es
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
informationen thomas